okay so that's the way this inverse
notation works I want to call back this
is the first example I showed you last
time but I gave you a second example so
i showed you up on the screen we went to
a fairly rapidly and the bell kind of
worthless but i wonder if you remember
example 2 okay it was this guy is now x
squared plus 1 what would happen if i do
this switching around business okay so
now i'm talking in terms of F and X
instead of Y and X so I'm not going to
switch x and y's i'm going to switch
these guys right so let's find what the
inverse of this is ok to find the
inverse i swap inputs in other words now
this is what we wrote before wrote this
last lesson in terms of X otherwise but
it looks ever so slightly different when
you've got these X's and eps okay so
here's what a minute firstly i can see
that you know how we wrote down no I
drop the board that you've got the area
of a circle and it's a function right so
therefore really in terms of function
notation I ought to write it like this
but no one writes it like that you
haven't been writing it like that for
years you kind of know intuitively area
is not just a number it's a function ok
that's what's status for so I'm doesn't
do the same thing here ok i'm going to
leave out that all apps i'm just going
to say f evening x squared plus 1 I just
want you to have in the back of your
mind f isn't just a number it's actually
a function right now when i switch on a
switch right I'll put that X there where
the f used to be
and what do i put x work now and work
out the inverse function ok so I'm going
to put in there f with a negative one ok
so now I'm talking about the inverse
I've switched them over ok squared plus
1 you care with them ok can we um can we
rearrange this a little bit so that just
like I have here I've got F inverse I
make that the subject can we do it
chicken kid let's have a shot keep give
me a suggestion what might I do is my
first line yeah good i'm going to
subtract 1 from both sides hmm that
seems familiar let's just quickly do it
x take away 1 square ok what do I do now
yeah the opposite of squaring is taking
the square root but watch out right I'll
take a square root look like this taking
the square root over here will look like
this but something's missing something's
missing isn't it ok a plus or minus is
missing right do you know why the plus
or minus is missing when you square
right this is saying well what number
can you square that will give you back
this ok now you seen this with like easy
numerical examples before right what's
the number that you square Thank You 25
the answer is well five is one of them
but it's not the only one is it right
you can get the negative as well ok
negative 5 you square it and just like
we saw in the morning the negatives will
cancel so here it's not just the
positive square root I have to include
this guy do you remember that all right
now let's tidy this up I'm going to
write this guy on the left hand side now
that I've finished doing all my
manipulation I'll put I'll put this back
where it belongs ok and then I write
this now this is both really good but
also really bad right because we're
doing inverse functions this whole time
right inverse functions go back go back
to like last week's notes what is a
function what's the flip side
definition of a function we talked about
like currency and stuff a function is
like it's a rule that will take exactly
one input and give you what exactly one
output right exactly one in exactly one
out I have a huge problem here right if
you give me one in this one symbol
single-handedly says I'll give you two
outputs but do you see that I mean just
as a quick easy the example that's put
in a number like say or 10 sorry um 17
okay when I evaluate this guy i'm going
to go plus or minus square root of i'm
just going to faithfully replace all my
exes with 17 okay 17 take one which of
course is 16 and so I've got two numbers
two numbers this is not a function right
this is in fact what's it called when
it's not a function start of our it's a
relation I these two quantities they are
connected they are related that's home
but they're related like like a circle
is ok I'm getting two numbers out ok so
this is in fact not any of those
functions i'm just going to write that
ok this is more an inverse function ok
and the reason why is it doesn't just
have one output for every port at least
in this case and i really need one it's
got to write well i can have three or
four depending on the function you get
your work at different universe ok it is
an inverse what do we call it again in
our relation it is an inverse relation I
get two outputs for one input first
ok